hi guys it's the J family we got banned
from Disneyland and this is that story
it was a normal day when Disneyland we
took our two kids want to have a good
time her sister-in-law was in town so I
wanted to take him other Disneyland
we had annual passes and we lived just
like 15 minutes from Disneyland so we
went with this specific day was actually
the second time I went that day I went
that morning for a couple hours and then
I was headed back with her whole family
go again he went there morning to get
macaron so we're there about evening and
we're going on some Ryan's and then we
had the idea to go on higher side
artists favorite ride
she loves pirates so we thought let's
take her on fire we've been on that ride
probably 20 times never had an issue but
this day was different but today um
because I had the idea as well that I
wanted to go get some more macaroons so
I said I will go get some macaroons you
guys go get in line and then I'll meet
up with you guys in line with meet the
macaroons of mine before we get on the
ride the lines usually pretty long and
it goes really slow so we thought she
got time to give her a macaroon make it
back before we done the ride we're off
so she goes to her macaroons I take the
kids and her sister-in-law we get in
line we're in a line I'm realizing he's
moving pretty quick today so I called
her hey Maile this line who really fed
how bad is your lime and I said this
like like I'm not even close this line
is really slow I'm ditching the
macaroons I'm just gonna gonna go get in
line with you guys I'm still moving
forward in line like I think twice about
it I'm still more for thinking she's on
her way so you'll make it in time so I
get to the front of the line by the into
the building where the rice start I'll
call her again
where are you this line I'm in the
building yes it's moving really quick
worried she said I said I'm in line I
was like one of
really annoying people I guess excuse me
excuse me we even in and out trying to
get through this big long line and I'm
moving fast at this line thinking I'm
gonna see them any second well so I get
to the front of the would par if you've
been to Disneyland you know the Pirates
right you know the wood I'm talking
about so I get to that point on like
Miley I call you in my room we're about
to get on the boat where are you like
we're getting on Nick they're counting
us out we didn't know she says I'm in
the building like I'm about to get on a
little part to right there I was so
close
I'll pick you okay so she's 15 nowhere
in my mind did not think maybe I should
just wait for her let me just with a
couple people go not just wait I don't
know but we did not wait we just kept
going so I get on the ride I got I
stepped on a bone I'm thinking she ain't
gonna make it
she's not gonna get on this ride with us
but little did I know so he tells me
we're on a boat and I can see that
they're about and so I tell the lady in
the front like still counting people on
the next one and I said my family my
husband and my kids are on that boat
here and go beyond the boat and just
like this one I said yeah they're right
there and so she says okay hurry and
like moves the rope for me to get past
her and go cannot so that's my go ahead
but then the boats shift to where we're
the next people who's about to take off
the start they're like farther they're
kind of hard to get to now because they
shifted forward my brain wasn't working
as normal brain in that moment thought
oh it only was thinking one thing I
gotta get on pirates I'm getting on this
road that's all I could think and
there's this one little like gate type
thing stopping me right that's all
that's coming between me and getting on
the ride with you guys and they're in
the back row of the boat so I'm only a
couple feet away I can just like step in
the book but at this moment I hear ma'am
ma'am you cannot you cannot do that
ma'am stop do that I'm only folks again
then one lady gave me the go-ahead and
I'm gonna get on the phone like I can't
I got this close I go to step on the
boat and at that same moment the boat
stalls at that moment I should have
logically put my foot back down on the
ground
20 minutes guys
oh come on the ride committed and as the
ride it started go to the back row and I
sat down and I immediately you did but
it was instant instant regret don't you
sit down oh just as fast as they were
amazed the second after that was guide
this is really bad I'm gonna get in so
much trouble this is bad I try to
reassure like no you're good like
they're not gonna care that much like
you're finally baby they just you're
good I was stressed I knew immediately
that was so dumb I'm about to get my
past taken away and I was so nervous the
whole time she tried to disguise
ourselves so I was ruining Raj she's
asking our sister-in-law do you have a
hair tie sweater I can put it off so I
can change the way how can you imagine
me up stakes to 250 pounds wearing a
pink hoodie I couldn't blend it with no
we didn't blend in at all our family the
riot we were realizing her on the ride
it was so backed up his rise never
backed up like this yeah and we're
thinking why would it be back though and
my don't live there looking for me it
didn't cross my mind oh they're probably
searching boats for me not until we were
like actually pulling up and I could see
that that's what they were doing
we finally got close to the end where we
could see that literally there was
security guards inspecting every boat
that's what was taking so long as they
were searching one mile and they were
looking for I was terrified at this
point so that's what we're really making
the plan like no we just gotta get out
get out go don't look at them they call
your name they say hey ma'am stop
don't listen just go and I am
made it like out I was I could have been
alright yeah I was off the boat I was
pretty far right and then I realized
that my sister-in-law and my nephew they
stopped me Trey do you know that lady
take it off the phone I think is I was
gonna lie and say no but my Lee comes
back I do not want this story to
escalate to them chasing me down and
like it's just gonna be so bad like I
felt really bad at this time do you I
was so scared and just like pneumo
stupid it was like I just like apologize
like crazy like that's my best bet I
just need to tell them I know it was
very timid I'm very sorry
they tell me like I think you already
know whatever like yeah I know it was
really dumb I'm just like what were you
thinking you can't jump onto a moving
right but then she says your ID and your
password yeah I know it I knew it in
that moment I can't flee and they're
probably obfuscate my past so I say to
her like can I stay like what it what's
going on and she says oh no we're we're
taking your pass you're done here you're
getting kicked out tonight we're
removing you from the park she's like
yeah you're banned your pass your pass
is an old that's confiscated you can't
come back come back man the kids could
stay but we decided to be team players
they can stay so they're walking us
through the park all the way to the
entrance and we thinking that's it like
they're not gonna walk with any further
than the entry within the guy smiley
ma'am yeah what parking lot are you in
and then he said you have to walk me to
my car come on like I feel like I'm a
fugitive so we got to the car and like
my daughter's telling me like it's okay
mom we'll just come back when you're not
in trouble anymore
[Music]
you forgive me
eventually the time came where we
decided to let's see cuz I pass it
expired we big knock pass expire so now
maybe they'll let her get a new pack
they don't know it's gonna get that past
that was like let's just go buy new
house mm-hmm I was very stressed it took
her like like 30 minutes Your Honor my
computer like obviously please must save
it so I'm gonna have to pop cuz it took
way longer than it should have but she
didn't say anything she just gave me the
pass and I was not gonna ask any more
questions and left it up back so here we
go yeah I actually have a basket now
good and I have been on Pirates of the
Caribbean since then she did not jump on
this time job you waited in line didn't
miss me what security does not play I
felt horrible and I was so embarrassed
and I definitely learned from that and
like I'm so on top of my game keeping
every rule how did you man and you need
to because you'll get kicked out so my
advice if you're ever waiting for
somebody for a ride just let people pack
professor it's not work at the keep
moving forward because you'll be into
things like this so advice step back you
go in front of me
oh now you're person through
[Music]
you